come to this video playing oj for oj
form from Norway okay yes this is the
antidote for others the Trump of ski in
Boris a Brooks book beating d for
something it's called beating d for
deviations or something like that I keep
forgetting the name okay it should be
five
mm what do you play here Queen 85 and 90
form this kind of stuff is this is this
some not really okay interesting chatter
interesting ok Knight c3 e5 just
blunders this so probably six maybe can
play Queen to d4 here covering c5 in
that way now he can yes he can hmm
interesting
okay maybe we'll take on c6 now I guess
with the poem Queen a 3a this looks very
very shaky but don't see how it wraps
the Queen and I need a neat this ideas
like a five and the in the position or
say if I've not good now high five don't
really see a reply to that at least no
good one we move to the be polite xe5
with the bishop very nice and I'm
threatening just to take on before it
looks strange a bit really rook be one
maybe can still I take on before
I think I'll just dink yeah and now
what's now interesting I can try maybe
look at eight seven actually queener
those are ok for is a very very
strange-looking but it is so probably
the response if I go Quinn 85 or queen
87 route 85 is ridiculous i just wrote
the eight very very remarkable yeah well
ok the c5 point is not very strong
anyway so it's not clear that I need to
get to it quickly okay maybe just
complete development
my idea was that he cannot really keep
control will oversee five-year I group c
8 and c5 if it looks it looks quite okay
and I just need to get these six back to
have a really good position don't really
see how he will keep that okay maybe he
can with the Queen from f4 or something
yeah that feels like a good position
really
so we'll just see 50 or maybe rooked
here for this kind of stuff should i
play five maybe just controlling lots of
squares yeah that sounds goodness it
controls fyd for f-4s Sam prevented yeah
it cannot be attacked at the moment well
okay maybe with f4 but this looks like a
very low smooth
maybe I'm threatening c5 and d4 here
really yes sir but before singing
this is also why couldn't move the Queen
really white resides yeah tricky I
really don't know this is this is a
known opening line I thought that should
be really good for me it looks it looks
very young hello it does not look very
harmonious for white it's this kind of
this kind of position maybe it is Sir it
is roughly okay but not sure funny is
that i wanted to originally play this
move but this rope a form in turn Jim
I'm a bit astonished that the engine is
giving it as + 44 white or three points
something now it looks very good route
be one is coming with the tempo even
zone yeah well okay i discarded queen a
7mm anyway and we should be seven is
also the computer move I mean okay if I
cannot move the Queen what else do I
move him as I must play that basically
takes takes and castles and no black is
better because the engine confirms that
so I was on the right track here the
thing is that his pieces are so clumsily
placed for those square c 585 here we
cannot really get control over that and
our here c5 already was a strong and
that I should that I should have
calculated a bit because it's so forcing
yeah yeah something like that I will get
both rooks back both rocks both nights
for the rook would have been interesting
to try but I don't think oops sorry put
this again this this wasn't bad problem
Queen edge form e 5 and the computer now
gives rook f2
be one with with roughly equal play
maybe I could have done something better
that's possible this should be roughly
equal I was thinking I'm about c5 the
idea at least to push c5 and even d4 and
now the comp gives this line and then f1
okay this is some this is very very
complicated hard to judge I mean black
should be okay in a way but it's it's
very very tricky it's got this strange
pawn on d6 center or probably for an
white has those really clumsy pieces
they don't do much I mean nights are
okay but they need they need a stable
positions and here they are basically
tied together then both nights cannot
really move and this makes it very
difficult for white to improve him the
compounds to play f5 which is quite
quite funny I don't really understand it
/ take it I fatigue either take it it
wants to force a draw with this
perpetual attack on the queer that's at
school so this is basically trying to
force a draw in a way so I don't need to
take it really but what do I play will
not take it something like that maybe
improving with don't really see anything
concrete here that helps let's say look
a 6 for example and maybe this is a play
along yeah it's very tricky very tricky
dirty blonde of the look alright thanks
for watching